ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Hello, and welcome
to another great exciting
episode of "Googles Developers
Live."
My name is Arun
Nagarajan, and I'm
with the Google Apps
Developer Relations Team.
And we're actually live
here from our studios.
We have a great partner,
PandaDoc, that's joining us.
And they're going to be walking
us through a great add-on
that they've built
for Google Docs.
And we'll have a conversation,
but more importantly, also
see a demo of the
product, itself.
But before we get started with
some of the technical demos,
and the product stuff,
tell me a little bit
about what the company does.
What are your typical products?
And what are some of the use
cases you're trying to solve?
DUSTIN YODER: Yes, so we
built PandaDoc out of the idea
that we had another application
that we were sending proposals.
And what we realized
is people wanted
to send all kinds of documents.
They wanted people to be
able to sign, comment,
annotate, and even track
the document they sent out.
So that's where
PandaDoc came from.
And with the PandaDoc
Google add-on,
or the add-on to Google,
it allows any document
to be uploaded, sent to anyone
you choose, and then you
can comment back and forth,
sign in, and get confirmation
that they've opened
it, signed it,
and you can communicate
right inside.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So it's a whole
electronic document workflow?
DUSTIN YODER: Exactly,
but it's all inside,
and so it's just
one clean workflow.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
And who is a typical user?
And who are using
PandaDoc today?
DUSTIN YODER: Yes, so we created
it with the consumer and SMB
in mind.
So we thought there was this big
gap in these smaller companies,
and the everyday
user like ourselves,
the 25-person software
company, sending documents.
We didn't have these enterprise
applications for doing this.
And so we all use the Google
Docs and all the other document
storage companies.
And we said, let's
build something
that works with these guys.
And since we use Google
Docs inside our company,
and we know a lot of other
consumers and SMBs do,
we said let's build it for them,
and give it to them for free,
and have a great
product for them.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Perfect.
And how does the Google add-ons
for sheets, for Docs rather,
help a business?
Like what are some
of the selling
points of the integration?
SASHA KOVALIOV: So the first
one is seamless integration
with your processes, actually.
So you don't have to two or
three different applications,
everything is done
inside Google Docs?
The other one is simplicity.
It's very simple, as we'll
see later in the demo
how it's done.
And we have a really clearer UI.
A lot of people are complaining
that right now the e-signature
in software and applications,
they're a pain to use.
We've devised PandaDoc
with a clearer UI,
from the very beginning.
And this is the main benefits.
And we've built it really fast.
It took us only a month,
month and a half to do,
and we'll see how it works.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
That's great.
Let's take a look at the demo.
SASHA KOVALIOV:
Yeah, absolutely.
So we were using
Google Docs, ourselves.
And we hate to use three,
four, or five tools
to just send and complete a doc.
So that's why we decided
to build PandaDoc.
And I'll show you how easy
it is to send a document.
So I'm sending an agreement
to Dustin for him to sign.
So let's see how it works.
You login into your Google
Docs, and you open your doc.
So you have PandaDoc
menu on the top,
you open the PandaDoc
panel, and we
will define who are we
going to send it to.
So we're sending it to Dustin,
so we type Dustin's email.
And we need to add
several widgets,
so name, it will be filled by
Dustin, we select and enter.
This will be filled by Dustin.
Then we will add
a Date Selector,
which again will be
completed by Dustin.
And the last one
is his signature.
So we add a Signature
block into the document.
And when we're done,
we just click Send,
and we will be able to insert
a small note to say, Dustin,
what we want him to do.
So we'll just say, hey Dustin,
just please sign and date,
so we can start.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And all of
that is fully integrated
into Google Docs?
SASHA KOVALIOV: Absolutely.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You
haven't left the doc yet?
SASHA KOVALIOV: We
don't leave anything.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
SASHA KOVALIOV: So
we send him the doc.
We can open the doc in PandaDoc
now, to look at the timeline,
and to track activity.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And this is
your tool, this is the web app?
SASHA KOVALIOV: This is
yes, this is the web app.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Great.
SASHA KOVALIOV: And we can see
what fields Dustin has to fill.
Let's take a look
at what Dustin has
to do to complete the document.
So he gets an email,
he opens the document,
and he can fill the document
in three simple steps.
He enters his email,
he picks the date,
and then he adds his signature.
He can upload his
PNG, he can draw,
or he can just select
the typed signature.
He clicks, Complete the
Document, and this is it.
It's done.
I can track all the activity.
I can track when Dustin
opens the document.
We have the notification,
we have the Dashboard.
So whenever somebody
says, well I
haven't received the
document, I can say,
well I see you have received it.
And also we give you the
legally binding PDF copy,
for your old-style users,
with a certificate and IP
address and the hash.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: If you
had to actually print it?
SASHA KOVALIOV: Yeah,
if you need to print it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
That's awesome.
And I think you
mentioned that it
took about a month and
a half to build this?
SASHA KOVALIOV:
Yeah, about that.
So API is very easy to use.
There is really
good documentation.
And let me quickly go
through how it was built.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah
let's take a look.
SASHA KOVALIOV: So
as you can see here,
the plug-in itself consists
of two sides, the panel
and whatever happens
on the server, right?
So, there's a server side,
which is actually a script.
And we have HTML Panel client,
which talks to the server side.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Great.
SASHA KOVALIOV: All
the widgets here, we
inserted them as images
into the Google Doc,
and we'll link them to
the appropriate instances
into PandaDoc.
So when you click
Send, all the images
will be transformed into HTML
slices in PandaDoc, which
the signee can fill
in, and sign them.
So in a nutshell,
this is how it works.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
That's very cool.
Thank you very much for sharing
all the details of your add-on,
and also some of
the business context
of why you built
this add-on, and what
you're looking to get out of it.
I've personally used
the add-on, and I
think it's a really
awesome add-on.
These guys have
done a terrific job.
Good luck with the
launch, and we really
hope you guys out there
check it out, and give us
a lot of feedback on it.
Thank you very much.
DUSTIN YODER AND SASHA
KOVALIOV: Thank you.